hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
leveling is one of the themes that has
come to be most closely
associated with the general idea running
behind siri and kierkegaard's
essay the present age which is part of a
larger review essay the two
ages and it's viewed by him
as a process that that really takes off
in modernity and in large part as we're
going to discuss
because of the generation of what he
calls a public
and and the press here we want to focus
on well what is
this this leveling in the first place we
want to wrap our heads
around what he has to say about that and
one of the
best places to start is his discussion
about
envy and how envy takes the
the form of leveling he doesn't just say
that
envy is a motive
that then leads to the process of of
leveling
instead he says it takes the form of so
envy not just in the sense of any sort
of
random invidiousness or
wishing that you had what somebody else
had or wanting to sort of tear them down
he talks about this this age the present
age
as having envy as a negatively
unifying principle in a passionless
and very reflective age and he says i
mean
this both in a non-ethical sense and
also in an ethical sense
so envy as this negative unifying
principle
as he says becomes leveling envy in the
process of establishing itself
takes this form and then he has a
contrast here he says that whereas a
passionate age
accelerates raises up and overthrows
elevates and debases you know brings
something up and then crashes it down
what a reflective apathetic
age does is the opposite of that
he says it stifles and impedes it
levels and we might also think about it
another term that we could bring in
there
is it reduces it it instead of just
simply like
raising things up to pull them down it
it
slowly pulls them down it erodes it
tries to put everything
on the same level which is why it's
called leveling
and what is he talking about it doing
there he doesn't he doesn't give us the
objects of this at that point
but individuality the individuality of
all those individuals out there they
remain individuals in sort of an
abstract sense but they're brought
within what in other places kierkegaard
will call the crowd
or the public in this essay
they're also doing this to
excellence he's got a great metaphor
about
this age allowing things to remain in
place
but just kind of slowing everything down
make it hindering it
making it impossible to really be the
excellence
that it aims at being and he talks about
leveling this is very interesting as
being a
mathematical abstract enterprise
so it's also a power it's another term
that he uses
for it and you might say what is he
talking about
mathematics for why does that matter
and you could see in this just sort of a
hostility of the
humanities perspective against you know
what we nowadays call the stem
perspective or you know science and
mathematics and
techniques what we call engineering
right in the stem
thing well it's not really that as such
instead it's there's something else
going on there
so if we follow out what he says
here's here's a very important passage
he says that
leveling is an abstract power and as
abstractions
victory over individuals in modern times
leveling his reflections correlative to
fate in antiquity and then here he tells
us something that gets towards
the the mathematics part the the
dialectic of antiquity was oriented
towards the eminent the great individual
and then the crowd
one free person then the slaves at
present the dialectic of christianity is
oriented towards representation
the majority perceive themselves in the
representative and are liberated by the
awareness
that he is representing them in a kind
of self-consciousness
the dialectic of the present age as
opposed to those
is oriented towards equality
and its most logical implementation
albeit abortive is leveling the negative
unity
of the negative mutual reciprocity of
individuals let's say that one more time
the negative unity
of the negative mutual reciprocity of
individuals so we have two things that
are
important here unity and reciprocity and
they're made negative in a way and how
can that be done well through this
notion
of equality and a kind of
mathematical equality in this this case
so he he goes on any i'm going to skip a
little bit of this he talks about
[Music]
in order to determine how much the
excellent individual
is worth the coinage standard has been
changed
so that about so and so many human
beings
uniformly make one individual
thus it's merely a matter of getting the
proper number and then one has
significance now that isn't that a weird
paradoxical way to talk about it
you take a number of people and they
become
well they don't become they make up they
comprise
an individual what can stand for
a center of agency what can speak
for itself what can take a stand what is
he saying there he's saying that
for so many people in an age of leveling
and this is part of what brings about
the leveling process
they don't want to do things on their
own they don't want to take a stand
by themselves and by putting together a
certain number which then can be
compared with other numbers which can be
quantified which can be polled which can
be turned into as we would say today
data you get
what we typically would view as a center
of agency and responsibility
so he says nowadays we all
understand that so and so many people
make one individual and in all
consistency we compute
numbers we call it joining together but
that's an euphemism
in connection with the most trivial
things now doesn't that look forward to
our own time
in which people come up with all sorts
of you know
marketing research polling data
and people say oh that must be the case
if that's so
i'll give you a prime example of this
sort of mindset that i've used
in other places my mother had a
boyfriend who was a pr
person he had his own firm pr is very
much public relations
oriented towards that sort of thing he
had free tickets
uh for a band here in milwaukee and he
wanted to give these free tickets to me
and a friend of mine and we were like
well we don't like that band
and he was like yeah but i mean they've
sold this number of albums
and all these people like it and this
you know the concert has this many seats
and we were like what the hell does that
matter you know
we don't we're not interested in seeing
this band live
and you could see in his in his eyes
there was an incomprehension there
and he kept saying the same things over
and over again but
but their their their their album is at
number one
on the top 40 and we were like that
doesn't matter that's not what makes for
musical quality nor
reaches us as people but there is a
mindset that views things that way oh
this person has that many twitter
followers
they must be good they must have
something
you know to say that the rest of us
should listen to
this person is on the news with all this
panoply of other people behind them
behind the scenes making this thing
happen well what they say must be
if not necessarily true at least
interesting
and worth chattering about as we go to
work the next day
so this this mathematical thing
he says a bit more about this that's
that's quite important as well
he says even if a small group of people
had the courage to meet death we today
would not say that each individual had
the courage to do that for what the
individual
fears more than death is reflections
judgment upon
him reflections objection to his wanting
to venture something
as an individual the individual does not
belong to god to himself to the beloved
to his art to his scholarship
no just as the serf belongs to an estate
so the individual realizes
that in every respect he belongs to an
abstraction in which reflection
subordinates him
and it was if a group of people in our
age could decide each one individually
to give all his fortune to some good
cause it would not
follow as a matter of course that the
individual could decide to do it
and again not because he was irresolute
about renouncing his fortune
but because he feared the judgment of
reflection more than he feared
poverty if 10 persons could agree to
affirm the full and unqualified validity
of erotic love or with no crippling
considerations limited justification of
enthusiasm it would not therefore follow
that each of the ten would be able to do
it
for they would still ambiva ambivalently
love reflections judgment
even more than the rapture of love and
the witnessing of enthusiasm with their
spirit
therefore ten would have to agree on
something in which it is a contradiction
to be more
than one and he calls us the idolized
positive principle of sociality in our
time and calls it the consuming
demoralizing principle that transforms
even virtues into
splutter splendid or glittering vices
and so this is this is what he's getting
at and talking about this as being a
mathematical
uh power or process or
whatever else leveling is we also want
to think about the
abstraction part of it so
he calls leveling a reflection game
in the hand of an abstract power it
it derives its power in part from
reflection and the relations between
humans and each other mediated through
their ideas
about and their fears and desires about
what the other people
think of them or will make of them and
he tells us this is quite interesting
nobody
can actually halt this process why not
because
every time that you try to resist it you
actually play into it so
he says a demon no individual can
control is conjured up although the
individual
selfishly enjoys the abstraction during
the brief moment of pleasure in the
leveling
he's also underwriting his own downfall
the forward thrust of the enthusiast may
end with his downfall but the leveler's
success
is ao ipso by that very fact
his downfall no period
no age therefore not the present one can
halt the skepticism of leveling
for the moment it wants to halt leveling
it will once again
exemplify the law he says a little bit
later
no particular individual will be able to
halt the abstraction of leveling for
it's a negatively superior force
to the individual and the age of heroes
is past you won't be able to stand out
against it and he gives
not just examples of like you know
heroes that we typically think of
but heroes within the realm of
spirituality and ideas
reformers for example
says no assemblage will be able to halt
the abstraction of leveling
for in the context of reflection the
assemblage itself is
in the service of leveling
the minute that you put together a group
of people to try to stop this leveling
process
you know for example to stand up for
western civilization
as you see all these people out there
doing this today and you're like
man you are the the biggest conformists
of anybody
that i've seen right you don't even
understand what western civilization
is because you're you're essentially
engaging in your own sort of hive
mind sort of thing and he says not even
national individuality will be able to
halt it why
the abstraction of leveling is related
to a higher negativity
pure humanity so
this sounds very pessimistic doesn't it
nobody can stop the process now
he he does say at certain points well
not everything is leveling in this sense
right
it can only take place partially by
things that he calls
concretions and a prime example of his
discussion of this is a little bit later
he says that uh here we go
the public is not a people we're going
to talk about the public nor a
generation nor one's age nor a
congregation not an association
not some particular persons for these
are what they are
only by being concretions so
in so far as there is still some like
well we're from this part of town
or we're thinking about things in this
way there's still some like
resistance to leveling but leveling will
come along and chew that up
and any attempt to try to hold on to
those sorts of things usually play into
the hand of leveling
he talks also about the what what really
drives and culminates the spirit of
leveling
in what he's calling the present age
which is what he calls
the uh public he
goes on and he he says that
here we go for a long time the basic
tendency of our modern age has been
towards leveling by way of numerous
upheavals none of them was leveling
because none was sufficiently abstract
but had a concretion of actuality
an approximate leveling can take place
through a clash of leaders resulting in
the weakening of both
or through one leaders neutralizing the
other the union of the essentially
weaker ones so they become stronger
and approximate leveling can be
accomplished by a particular social
class
or profession for example the clergy the
middle class the farmers or by the
people themselves
but all this is still the moment of
abstraction within the concretions of
individuality
what changes it says for leveling to
really take place
you need a phantom the spirit of
leveling a monstrous abstraction
and all encompassing something that is
nothing a mirage
that is the public the public is not the
same thing
as people the public is an abstraction
and it's there it's been called by
different names by other existentialist
authors but it's there as an abstraction
that sort of
haunts us you can never find it at any
given point and yet it's always
when you turn your head ready to talk to
you and people will speak
on behalf of the public to tell you
you've got things wrong or got things
right
you're a good person a bad person now
the last thing to say about leveling is
that
in a certain sense leveling is
irresistible
but it depends on what ground we're
looking at it's not truly
irresistible for the single individual
he tells us this is a beautiful passage
here he says
in its immediate and beautiful form the
principle
of individuality prefigures the
generation
in the person of excellence the leader
and
has the subordinate individuals group
around the representative
so that's that's the way things used to
go right and could still go today
although leveling will come in and you
know take its toll
then he says in its eternal truth
the principle of individuality uses the
abstraction
and equality of the generation as
levelers
thereby religiously develops the
cooperating individual into an
essentially
human being so there's an opportunity
here for the
the individual within a context of
leveling
to evade it and surpass
it now it's not going to be in a way
that's going to get accolades
or people saying wow i need to write a
medium article or do a video or
or you know do an expose about this
person who's evaded leveling that
it's not going to be visible in that
sense
those are just are not going to be
possibilities if you are the
the individual be ready for people not
to recognize you as as such
but he says this leveling
is just as powerful with respect to the
temporary
the secular world even including much of
the religious right insofar as they're
worried about you know should we pave
the
the driveway uh should we you know uh
what what color should the vestments be
and all these sorts of things
so he says uh it it's powerful with
respect to the temporary with the age
as it is impotent with respect to the
eternal
reflection is a snare in which one is
trapped but in and through he says
the inspired leap of religiousness this
this commitment
the situation changes and it is the
snare that catapults one into the
embrace
of the eternal so there is a possibility
for the individual to
not be sucked into this process of
leveling
at the same time
you know they can't get some sort of
ratification or recognition
except from other single individuals
which isn't going to matter for the
crowd or the public or
the institutions that they're in if it
does it'll be completely contingent
and probably eroded by leveling
how many here's what we ought to end on
if kierkegaard is right about this
how many single individuals have in fact
resisted this this power of leveling
including kierkegaard himself we don't
know
we couldn't know because it's not
something that you can tabulate
put into a nice spreadsheet or data set
it's not going to fit that sort of
paradigm
so what we've got here is this process
that
that kierkegaard thinks is happening
it's been accelerating
in our own time it's changed in its
nature
and particularly so because of the
relation to the public
and the press but it is something that
isn't an inevitable
going-under of individuality although it
is an ever-present danger
you